I really think that the more important
thing right now is not the facts I think
that the proliferation of digital media
and simply web tools makes for just
knowing facts to be less significant I'm
sort of less concerned about what are
the top 10 things that every person
needs to know about DNA or that they
should be able to pronounce
deoxyribonucleic acid or they should be
able to list the planet so they should
be able to tell you what a stem cell is
although all those things are valuable
and certainly you can go deeper into a
conversation if you can skip the step of
going to Wikipedia and checking what it
is but you can go and you can go to
google and check what it is and there's
a great plethora of information that
will you know satisfy that objective so
I'm kind of less concerned about the
data points I don't know what the data
point should be that to me is a tertiary
matter that will work out once we figure
out the bigger issues now which is what
should people be thinking about science
and that to me is truly what science is
we need a much better understanding what
science is and why science works the way
it works what peer review is how science
achieves goal when we read something on
the you know page 1 of our newspapers in
any part of the world and it simply says
scientists at insert University here
today announced that we immediately skip
to discovery we immediately skip to the
outcome the output of science and we
don't have a sense of the input into
science and I think that's terribly
deleterious to our notions of what
science is because if all we see is this
output is science kind of churning out
results and data and things in a kind of
mechanical process of manufacturing sort
of resource for society then we forget
that it's actually people human beings
who may also have liberal arts
backgrounds and then decided to study
science and have girlfriends and go to
movies and go see an art exhibit and
have life issues and have biases and
read books
and the way that they view these
problems which are becoming increasingly
nuanced they're the kinds of questions
that we're all very concerned about how
the human genome suggests things about
who we are the power of synthetic
biology to completely transform our
notions of security of asymmetric
warfare these are things that you know
the Large Hadron Collider in Geneva
that's trying to understand fundamental
questions about the nature of the
universe and who we are and where we
come from work in evolutionary biology I
mean these are questions that we are all
the work on the mine now to create more
complete maps of the human mind these
are things that we all are interested in
and scientists are the ones doing the
work signs are the ones that are
advancing our collective societal
notions of what these things are and if
we don't have a certain sense that
scientists themselves are getting input
as human beings from a variety of
different sources a be that within the
scientific community in order for them
to arrive at a conclusion and publish it
in a paper it has to go through a
process of peer review of vetting of the
rigor of the scientific method that
really does make science the best
intellectual instrument we have for
understanding things about the world
it's in fact because of what science is
it's because of the institution of
science that makes the output from
science so valuable to society and I
think that we've seen so many different
forces acting as I was saying before so
many different forces acting on science
that are disrupting it that we need to
come back to redefining what science
what we want signs to be what science is
how science works so we all really
genuinely have an understanding i think
the next step and it could be five years
of this is scientific literacy and what
everyone should think about about
science is simply what science is more
so than any one data point that comes
out of science